hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't escape 3 this game
was actually released six hours ago and
I love the past script welder series I
love script welder as a developer he
does a fantastic job on all the games
and he makes and I just so happened to
be here over at Wade's house recording a
few solo games so thank you to wade for
letting me use his space that's why it
doesn't look the same everybody don't
panic it's okay I am me and we are doing
this but this is don't escape three so I
don't know the premise for this one Oh
warning vacuum I wake up with a terrible
headache like if someone hit my head
really hard things were coming back to
me slowly I knew I was a pilot of this
starship the u EFS horizon but I had no
idea how I wound up in here I also had
no idea what I didn't like more the fact
that I woke up in the ship's airlock or
the fact that the computer was counting
down to something oh crap oh so that's
what we're all crap oh uh uh board
injection oh crap
life-form detected air aboard ejection
aboard ejection okay well I survived my
first travesty very quickly okay cool so
apparently I am NOT trying to escape
into the vacuum of space because that
would have been very bad
so decompression without a spacesuit
that would be suicide of an interior
door there we go okay I could initiate
injection procedure but I'll do that
after I beat the game and you can see
how a game overs that way okay what is
this that doesn't sound good
we've located what is left of the
derelict something tore it apart like a
tin can
we found something among the debris z'
remains i think they're human remains we
also found some strange glow and
crystals attached to the bones we
brought it on board for further analysis
dr. kronborg will perform tests in the
laboratory rick says there was another
crystal floating in space we'll have to
check to that later
yeah it couldn't be murderous aliens why
would it have been murdered aliens
navigation offline communications
offline warning lacks abode online it
will run out in one hour distress call
activated warning possible intruder
alert
oh so I'm not alone here good oh boy
okay so that's that's bad that's me okay
so what did I get anyway I got a
personal data pad fuse box one fuse is
missing
give lab okay so empty flask subject is
what appears to be an upper half of
human remains all the soft tissues
decomposed would suggest the death
occurred along before its exposure to
the vacuum of space there's a large
crystal form attached to the bones of
the abdominal region the crystal itself
produces the bright blue light despite
being highly energetic no other forms of
radiation have been observed however it
seems to be emitting subtle acoustic
vibration further tests are required
it's taking over our minds why would we
allow it on the ship why are we study it
okay
it sort of components this is amnesia I
have no idea what to do oh okay it's
probably gonna take a lot of wool
covered with blue crystals I'm imagining
that's a bad thing okay got an empty
flask okay crystal dissolving formula I
don't know amplifies explosive material
that does sound good
okay so I need three of those plus two
of those plus four of those and then
it'll all explode okay wait wait is that
another okay so don't do the one at the
bottom but definitely do the one on the
left but the one at the bottom okay one
on the left will dissolve the one on the
bottom there will explode so that's
probably useful in some regard somehow
hello open the pod bay doors I don't
have a thing to do that but if I put an
explosive on that maybe maybe just maybe
it'll work okay so I think I got no Dana
pad I didn't get a key card so I need to
go over here oh I see I can't go in
these kids oh hey Oh
so I don't have a whoo okay so I got a
plasma torch but no fuel and I devil is
I'm gonna be good for a
oh I don't think really I don't father
care for me I didn't know him well his
name was Rick I think he's dead
very dead something killed him ooh what
is that he'll buy some screws I don't
have anything to do that it's good on
the bridge oh hey you're dead dead
strangled help me get strangled oh crap
this is a u EF s Warsaw we've picked up
your distress call and we are setting
our course to intercept be advised we
won't be able to reach you for two days
from your signal we know that your
life-support system has failed if you
were unable to make repairs use the
escape pod and wait our survival arrival
good luck wait how much time do I have I
still have one hour so I haven't done
anything that could take time okay so I
got a fuse I can put that in the fuse
box
captain's console.log last entry ah crap
self destruct well probably I need to do
that access mission orders your mission
is to investigate the anomalous readings
in the sector we have detected what may
be a signature of one of our mining
ships that went missing a few years ago
move on to the designated coordinates
and scan the area if any signs with a
lost ship are detected investigate and
report back definitely do not bring
onboard the blue crystal aliens probably
very bad okay so does he have an access
code of some sort can I like steal can i
plunder his body please is this bad okay
fine whatever
so I did what I could there so I have a
fuse which means I can put that in the
fuse box right cheer cool oh did that
turn on the lights in the other dark
room maybe yes did I still don't want to
go in now let's go let's do this like a
boss not cool standard meal ration Bon
Apetit a cool take today's dessert cool
thank you
alcohol please lots of alcohol
I'm gonna need it okay so I got alcohol
which means might be fuel for the
plasmid or no of course it wouldn't be
that be to ingenuity cyst and not
chemically sound ooh boy what's in there
oh good the bathroom I can't wait for
this go horribly wrong
good detergent I don't have to use it
right now
sink here Amir oh crap did I somehow I
couldn't stare at my own reflection
what's that mean is there something
wrong with me there's something wrong
with me okay so yes okay so maybe I
could like if something if some other
alien is here maybe I could like I don't
know lay some food out you know lucky
this you know lucky this says bad news
written all over it
bad news written all over it
okay so either way I got more stuff now
that's good I guess
right okay so I need an ass coast card
to get that I can't go out that way
do I still have time left yeah I don't
think any time is actually past then
assuming that I've been doing okay okay
so I guess somehow do this maybe I could
do Oh
detergent maybe these are chemicals that
I can mix that's my only other thought
here that I could do I mean I don't want
to consult a walkthrough until I
absolutely know exactly what I'm doing
okay insert components Val of
antibiotics okay there we go ah so it is
a thing okay so I got two chemicals ah
there we go
begin mixing oh crap sure why not
it's the best bet I got probably not
gonna work why not gonna work okay thank
you thank you I'll put it in this flask
here thank you
oh boy what is it I have no idea what it
is oh okay
tell me what is it oh crap oh I didn't
know I wasn't paying attention
damn it okay well that's the thing
least I could get more I guess maybe
maybe I could take a flask of blood oh I
should do that I should get a flask of
blood I should totally do that then I
can chemically analyzed it and then
determine what it's made of and then in
the chemical mixture I should be able to
do what I need to do I can't get another
flask tits need to do i boned up
eyeballs doll over the place great Fermi
so I'm willing to bet this is bunk okay
there we go I emptied it out now I can
go get more let me go analyze blood can
I analyze blood please yes I can I can
indeed okay give me alcohol thank you
all right so I'm gonna go over here dun
dun woo who did that who is there
is that my reflection I can't stand to
see the side of is that why the oh I'm
the only survivor here result uploaded
to your data pad good let me look at
that
okay chemical analysis blood cells oh
cool cool okay cool okay so I just need
to analyze all this way I need to dump
this that's why that's there dump that
but oh oh I see I got it I'm hip to it I
got it
nice okey-dokey then okay so chemical
analysis all right so according to the
log I needed what did I need for solvent
I need three to four three to four okay
so I need to get three to four in some
combination here so I need whoo boy so I
need one blood cell
one detergent and something else that's
not gonna work anymore there got to be
more stuff that I can look up okay so I
got to find more stuff to analyze oh
they're all those more oh cool cool cool
cool
got it Oh some blood fuel for plasma
torch grass yes please creepy
I don't know this how would I know this
I don't know that prolly probably some
clue here at least I got more stuff to
analyze cool cool cool cool cool cool
cool cool cool cool cool so now but I
don't have a mask so I might blind
myself I'll probably be bad no reason to
scan that please okay what does the
plane leave yet chemical analysis please
yes exactly what I needed okay so I can
do it with the plant leaves blood and
then antibiotic yeah that would do it
right I need three to four plant leaves
blood antibiotics and then I got the
right mixture for dissolving okay let me
do that plant leaves blood antibodies
let me go get some more blood excuse me
third would you like to donate some
blood to a good cause I probably didn't
murder you at least I don't think I'll
go in here into the dark scary room sir
thank you for your donation I'll be on
my way now
bing-bam-boom mix yes I already wasted
time but hopefully I don't need all of
it what am I talking about of course I
need all of it okay so I got it put it
in the flask put the flask ins ding
won't open but it's but it's it's
correct it's correct
I know it's correct it's gotta be
correct fine I'll do this then it's a
product line me probably need that
protection the flare would burn my eyes
up damn it what a bunch of baloney maybe
I can use the knife as like a
screwdriver maybe I might be able to do
that yeah ok that worked ok i got a key
so the key goes to where that's an
excellent question maybe it goes to the
door here
this door here no what about the cabinet
yes okay cool
acid bottles goggles protective glasses
they look like really cool sunglasses
thank you very much okay
so I got that and now I've got that was
the last chemical that I needed so I got
the a suit as well so now I have all
that I can put these on and look really
cool who let go cool I look I mean look
how cool they look then put this in here
do this ahh whoa I have to do it
manually
very nice yeah but never like alien
isolation all over again done it
thank you ker clunk clunk cool okay so
this is good what is bad okay that
wasn't I bet I can't stay long in there
to repair with some tools like what
knife damn it okay I don't have tools
what Oh access card perfect so I got the
access card so now I can use the access
card to get in here there we go tools
perfect okay so I need the tools to go
do the thing almost almost almost repair
with some tools baby dip over taboo take
20 minutes damn it
that's like all my time chips engineer
he's dead you seem to be very dead okay
ooh that looks thing okay this looks
thing okay activate main life support a
day auxilary air reserves still degrees
damn it
fire girl maintains
okay how about the oh okay that's how I
do it I put this in the system yes and
then I text the sprinklers Oh in the
isolation ward BAM
yes cool so that must have done it right
what is that oh this is what I put in
the data cube okay or the disk data cube
all right what is that oh no way
oh wow I don't know what I need I have
no idea what I need so I'm gonna wait on
that one but I think that it is must
have dissolved everything in the lab yes
I knew it was correct I was right okay
poor soul Wow going in her head
explosive materials with no igniter okay
whoa log five
I was wrong really wrong the corpse
didn't rot for any period of time it's
been consumed by the crystal it's been
growing inside bursts that man opened
and continued to grow using soft tissues
as building material I think this is
what happened to the crew of the
destroyed ship and we might be next
as for now I'm working on a formula for
something that will dissolve the crystal
or at least weaken it so it may be
destroyed by force
an explosion might work the sound is
getting louder
indeed it is I probably shouldn't be in
here makes me really uneasy and tense
yeah no joke okay so I have was it was
that slappy sound
what does that sounds flappy sounds
sloppy every single time it goes up wait
don't I need it oh I could probably get
the suit there we go
okay I won't put it on just yet I guess
I don't know why I wouldn't but okay so
next I guess find out how to fix this
[ __ ] I'm beginning to think that maybe I
should leave everything alone in the
other people they sabotage the ship so
it wouldn't get out that's probably what
it is but if I was smart I would
probably blow all of this up okay so now
I need to make the explosive because I
know that I need a a more powerful
explosive and to do that I need 3 for 2
so 3 for 2 is what I need alcohol acid
and detergent alcohol acid and detergent
alcohol acid and detergent ok I got all
of those put that in there I've got that
explosive mixture so whoops nope those
two okay did that strong explosives now
are stronger but they still don't have
an igniter so I need mix in the igniter
of some sort to be able to do what I
need to do so to do that I still need
like the captain's key maybe I could
take the knife to the gap no portable
igniter it's sitting right there what
kind of idiot a my portable igniter of
course yes I need that
okay so Construction complete how about
I say thank you thank you very much now
I have a portable igniter for this ok
there we go
ok a powerful bomb because it's super
powerful yes you stayed a pad to
detonate ok so now I can get out
question back ok so if I I think about
this logically it looks like there's
pieces missing here down at the bottom
but these skate pods here I could put
the suit on eject detonate and then it
would all be blown up I would survive
and I'd be ok
question mark question mark I'm not sure
okay all right I don't know what else to
do at this point so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna put on the suit I'm gonna wear
it I'm gonna eject I'm gonna detonate
and then see where that leads me because
I never get this right on the first try
so then I might look up a walkthrough
and see oh the reason we're here of
course is a reason to wear it here I'm
in an escape pod yes wait wait wait wait
what something on board the horizon
killed everyone and tried to kill you it
had to be stopped
dr. God Berg's chemical recipe worked as
intended weakening the crystal and
making it vulnerable unfortunately you
had no idea how to destroy the crystal
what's even worse you never learned the
entire truth your escape pod was picked
up explosive all contact with the rescue
ship you ef-s Warsaw was lost to view as
after a crew picked up the escape pod
ship remains missing let's continue do
oh good okay good for me okay let me
look at walkthrough real quick BRB okay
so apparently the first thing I did
wrong let's go over here and in the bot
whoa what was that
hello okay okay I think I know what I
need to do I think I know I think I got
it I think I got it okay alright so what
I didn't see here is I didn't read close
enough here datapad mk2 processors so
mark to data pad that's what I need I
think that's as far as I looked in the
way I didn't actually look any farther
so I'm stupid but I got an upgraded one
now so what does this mean now status
security camera how is this any better
Oh better how is this better go
apparently I'm supposed to go here and
look at the security camera security
feed in this area has been corrupted and
cannot be displayed you can recover the
video but restoring the feed will
require users attention process will
take 15 minutes okay
I got some time just whoa hey
I was going on mr. spacesuit man what
are you doing yes you just stand-in
there you stand-in there being a creeper
okay
think he stopped the fans first wait Oh
what oh oh I'm doing this I thought he
was just creeping there like a weirdo
okay well that explains a lot
good good Oh restore more corrupted
video feed to reveal the passcode I
don't have enough time for that I'm
fairly certain I don't have enough time
oh maybe I do maybe I've barely enough
time so I just got a look at the feeds
try to find the feeds in various areas
probably where people have been murdered
if I had to get if I had a favor a guess
as to where this all went down probably
right about here security cam Lewis
hello yeah that's that's okay
Oh grab someone wearing a spacesuit
appears indeed and does something bad to
them I probably used a weapon or a tool
oh that's what he used the full canister
[Music]
that's not cool bro it's not cool okay
security camera yes oh boy it's taking
way too long
it's a kid is that a kid now can be a
kid they would have a kid on a spaceship
that's is a very short adult I know the
feel oh crap well uh it doesn't look too
happy
what the hell oh it was right up on the
screen I wasn't sure what happened there
okay cool
so nine three seven wait not enough so I
just got to go to the captain who was
strangled he was strangled
not available in this area really really
all right would have thought no well
where else would it have been maybe in
the airlock that makes sense because I
saw him in the airlock and I'm boiling
about it's me I'm willing to bet that
this dude is me probably what about the
lab here in here probably in here yeah
here we go
see this what are you doing that was
sudden and weird so okay fighting oh
[Music]
okay again all the numbers 9 3 & 6
cool nine three eight six and I
hopefully have enough time to do
everything that I need to do hmm
nine three eight six nine three eight
six let me double check make sure code
nine three eight six got it nine three
eight six there we go got it cool so I
go in I want to
oh honey [ __ ] you hello I should have
put on the space suit all the suit is
empty and that's my nametag it's going a
Saturday I went to sleep in it use me to
kill everyone oh my god
and then I tried to get rid of me in the
airlock oh okay
I'm infected I know what I must do is
this I must blow it all to hell blow it
all to hell
okay nothing else in there oh okay good
good good goody gumdrops okay cool this
is bizarre and weird so now do I blow it
all up small crystal that I coughed up
let me put this in the analyzer or
something I guess
no reason to scan it alright
Oh captain's access card I can go and
look at the captain's stuff cool cool
cool cool I hope I have enough time okay
here we go log last entry someone is
killing everyone rick is dead Jesse's
Devon I've locked myself up on the
bridge I will send a distress call and
captain oh my god lieutenant is that you
yes please let me in I've locked the
killer in the bunk room hang on I open
the door for you sounds of a struggle
log ends great don't trust anybody
safety protocols Curley online
deactivate
self-destruct unable to comply good well
I know what to do now I had time to boo
I don't look good time to blow it all up
which I should have done a while ago I
guess unless there's something else that
I need to do and I don't know what it is
but maybe I should just blow it all up
is my inclination as to what I need to
do yes please do that something on board
the horizon killed everyone and tried to
kill you it had to be stopped
dr. Grogg Berg's chemical recipe worked
as intended weakening the crystal and
making it vulnerable you tried to
destroy it with a bomb by blowing up the
whole ship just to be sure a powerful
blast left nothing behind or at least
that's what you hoped when you open the
bunk room you learned the truth the
crystal had possessed you somehow those
quiet acoustic vibrations were enough
for it to spread and start growing
inside your body you knew there was no
way out of it so you did what had to be
done when you detonated the charges the
explosion consumed you together with the
crystal yes chip contamination level
zero you ef-s Warsaw found nothing more
than scraps of metal floating in space
nobody knew what really happened until a
strange glow oh come on
come on I guess I did it though did I do
it
did I done it did I do it right I think
I did all right I think that might have
been it right I'm pretty sure let me
know if it's not but let me check a beer
I be okay I just checked yes that was
exactly what I was supposed to do so I
did it right good for me he did it
look at me I'm killed great and smart so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thanks for watching this video it was a
lot of fun I always loved these games by
script welder they are a blast to have a
pun in there I am in Wade's house and
waves recording room so it seems fitting
that but thanks getting everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
you